growing up in India like many of you I
got my first telephone when I was 12 in
my case it turned out to be a rotary
phone so it wasn't that great for
selfies but I still love to call my
friends play with it and sometimes take
it apart that telephone cemented my
fascination with technology I remember
in my parents house in Chennai reading
about the invention of the transistor at
Bell Labs of course that initial
invention helped found ward became known
as Silicon Valley and out of that came
companies like fat child semiconductor
and Intel and all the computers and
software that we all used today you can
draw a direct line from that invention
to the technology that powers your
Twitter feed or your WeChat messages
today I remember reading about that and
thinking it's the idea that matters it
didn't matter where you come from or
what your background is one
revolutionary idea one brilliant
invention can unleash other
entrepreneurs to revolutionize
industries in ways you could never
predict you will have many of many many
opportunity opportunities to reinvent
yourself and so you know so I think you
know it's worthwhile taking risks on
trying to do something you're really you
know excited by and if the first attempt
you don't do it you know you can try
again and you know things tend to work
out in the long run in Silicon Valley
you know you know parties and so many
people's startup or companies starting a
book company and even having failed you
know you can wear it like a badge of
honor right and I think that's important
you know culturally you know risk is
rewarded I remember when I started
working at Google you know I if I went
and you know people who are discussing
ideas to other people who heard the
ideas try to build on those ideas they
encourage you so it's a culture of
optimism it's a culture of risk-taking
and I think that's really important
you just watch - amazing clips with
sundar Pichai take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]